ellen page now goes by elliott page this
actress
says the backlash right now is so
intense
but the rhetoric coming from anti-trans
activists
and anti-lgbtq activists namely people
who
have two eyes and recognize that men are
not women it's devastating
these bills are going to be responsible
for the death of children
it's that simple okay i want to take
this argument on head on
because i think very often people will
write in
from the left and they'll say you just
don't understand this issue michael
you're straw manning this issue
sure men and women are different but
some people have this awful affliction
and if you don't indulge their fantasies
then you're killing them because they're
going to be depressed and suicidal
what about anorexics what about people
who are dangerously thin
but believe that they are fat
that's their truth that's their that's
their self-perception that's their
identity
they're fat people trapped inside of
thin people's bodies right
and if we don't indulge their delusion
they're going to be very sad and
depressed and upset you're literally
killing them
if you don't allow them to destroy their
bodies
what's the difference they're both body
dysmorphic disorders
this is actually what paul mchugh the
doctor who helped to pioneer the
transgender surgery at johns hopkins
university which was the institution
that pioneered
the gender ideology this is what he
concluded in the 70s he said
the surgery doesn't really do anything
to help people doesn't necessarily hurt
but it doesn't
as a psychological matter it obviously
hurts their physicality but it doesn't
it doesn't help them so he stopped doing
it you know who else was at johns
hopkins university
dr john money a sick pervert
who was totally bought in on gender
identity theory and
destroyed a young boy's life because he
as a little baby
mutilated the boy's genitals to make him
look more like a girl and conducted
heinous experiments on him
and both he and his brother developed
horrible
uh disorders and ultimately both killed
themselves
on the altar sacrificed on the altar of
this insane
theory i discussed this at great length
actually in my upcoming book
what's it called speechless controlling
words controlling minds available now
for pre-order
horrible horrible things perpetrated in
this name
on a false sense of compassion there is
nothing
compassionate about indulging the
anorexics delusions
and no amount of emotional manipulation
will will convince me that it is
there's another argument on the gender
theory which is this
yes men and women are different and
yeah that's not going to change reality
but these these men who think they're
women
are they're just caught in this
condition and there's no way out of it
and so it's better for them it's much
better for them
if they can mutilate their bodies to
look more like the other sex
before puberty sets in that's the
argument that
the actual strong argument for
castrating kids
relatively strong argument for
castrating kids is that
if you allow puberty to set in it's
going to be very difficult to mutilate
their bodies to look more like the other
sex
so you've got you actually have to do it
before
they're grown up before they have
developed their faculties of reason
totally
otherwise they're going to miss the
chance and you're going to be
responsible
you bigoted close-minded conservatives
you're going to be responsible
for killing people later on because you
wouldn't mutilate them when they were
kids
i see the quasi-logic of that argument
parents make decisions for kids
and they make some decisions for kids
because the kids are not old enough to
make those decisions themselves and so
the parents need to decide
to castrate the kids but we're not just
talking about
whether the kid is going to eat broccoli
or cheetos for dinner
we're not just talking about is the kid
going to learn violin or
guitar we're not just talking about is
he going to play football or baseball
we are talking about sexual decisions
for children and we are talking about
permanent
sexual decisions for children and it
raises this question someone wrote in
to me caitlyn burns who's written for
vox and msnbc
says by 18 the permanent effects of
natal puberty have set in so the state
has effectively made
decisions about their body without
giving adolescents any choice at all
any choices so the children need to have
choice
about sexual decisions and permanent
sexual decisions of that
but they're children they don't have
free choice
if this woman's argument or man i don't
know there i think there might be a
trans
transgender issue in this case i don't
know much about this person but if this
argument is correct
why do we have age of consent laws
why what's the point of an age of
consent law
the argument for an age of consent law
is that kids are too young to make
any sexual decisions much less permanent
ones
if we are now saying that children have
the right to
mutilate their genitals castrate
themselves
surely you would have to abolish age of
consent laws so i pointed this out this
is a very basic
argument and of course the disingenuous
left what do they do whenever you
whenever you make a a point like this
they say well you what stop sexualizing
children you're
you're trying to get rid of age of
consent laws i know
they don't really think that they're
just trying to get a cheap shot in no
quite the opposite
i'm trying to make it illegal to have
these surgeries
because this is extraordinarily
disordered and it's child abuse
and i don't think that children have
free agency
and i don't think that we should
sexualize children in the way that the
left has done
in a systematic way for decades
beginning with the bizarre
fantasies of wilhelm reich moving on to
the sick
child sexual experiments of dr john
money who
was that doctor at johns hopkins who
would who would have these two brothers
simulate sex
strip take photos of it all in the name
of some sort of perverted science
the the sexualization of children that
we saw in the early essays of bernie
sanders
in alternative newspapers in vermont who
would talk about how we need
children to become accustomed with to
their sexuality and experiment with one
another seriously it's in there
i mention it in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds the open enough
these are two totally different visions
and there's no compromise between those
things okay
and i think we're beginning to see as
the leftist
narrative gets so insane that you've got
left-wingers arguing for the total
sexualization of children to make
permanent sexual decisions
and the vast majority of people who look
at that and say man whatever that is
i'm out whatever that is i don't want it
you're seeing that break down now
how did we get this far how on earth
did the country get to the point that we
are seriously having
this debate hey all right am i still on
youtube for now or are they going to
take more of my videos down what
i don't know what it is even if we get
the videos up very often
you may not get a notification so make
sure you ring
the bell ring my bell ll ring my bell
subscribe like make sure that you put
yourself in the most likely position
to get notifications for our next videos
[Music]
you